[Musique]
dix mois
pourquoi c'est si dur pour toi de tuer
cet homme il connaît le moindre de mes
mouvements à la france
[Musique]
il est là je le tiens je lui tire dessus
et s'évapore comme un fantôme
[Musique]
tu sais
je crois savoir pourquoi il est aussi
fort que toi c'est toi ya 25 ans ils
t'ont créé à partir de mois qu'ils m'ont
choisi parce que je suis unique en son
genre il faut qu'on en finisse
tu as toutes ses capacités la souffrance
en moins
vous avez créé quelqu'un à partir de
quelqu'un d'autre
et vous m'avez chargé de cuir
vous avez choisi de me faire ça cette
chose contre laquelle tu luttes c'est la
peur
accepte la et sur monclar
il pouvait envoyer n'importe quel tu as
pourquoi es tu as choisi toi
[Musique]